لذلك اوضح مسؤولون عسكريون امرييون ان حزم
المساعدات العسكريه الاخيره لاوكرانيا لا
تمنع واشنطن من البحث عن المعدات العسكريه
الروسيه الصنع تلبي متطلبات المعركه على
حد تعبيرهم باعت ذلك في ظل توقعات باشتداد
نطاق الهجمات الروسيه والاوكرانيه خلال
الفتره القادمه وقال للجنرال لورا ريتشارد
سون قائد بالقائده الجنوبيه للولايات
المتحده ان واشنطن تعملوا مع الدول التي
لديها معدات روسيه اما للتبرع بها او
بتبديلها بمعده امريكيه
واضافت القائد ان المناقشات الجاريه مع ست
دول على وجه الخصوص ويعتقد الخبراء ان
الدول السيره المستهدفه والمكسيك
والاكوادور وكولومبيا واوروجواي
والارجنتين والبرازيل ويعتقد قالته ان
روسيا التي تستعد على ما يبدو لحرب طويله
الامل ستحاول ارهاق اوكرانيا بوابل من
الهجمات
صوره عدم تسريع المساعدات واغرق اوكرانيا
بمعدات غير جاهزه لاستخدامها